grenzkontrollen urlaubsreisen impfstoffe
im kampf gegen die korona pandemie ringt
die eu um eine gemeinsame lösung testen
testen testen der bundestag streitet
über den raschen einsatz von corona
schnelltests großrazzia gegen radikale
islamisten berlin verbietet eine
vereinigung mutmaßlicher es
sympathisanten
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
christian sieversen abend in allen ich
begrüße sie ganz herzlich bei uns hier
gemeinsam mit katja stresow vom sport
und wer geimpft ist soll wieder reisen
können so schlagen dass mehrere
urlaubsländer in der eu vor und fordern
einen speziellen impfpass das ist ein
umstrittenes thema heute auf dem video
gipfel von europas staats und
regierungschefs es geht dabei um
schwierige fragen um die sommersaison
und das heikle thema grenzkontrollen
stefan leifert berichtet aus brüssel
diese bilder wollte die eu eigentlich
nicht mehr produzieren doch an europas
binnengrenzen wird wieder kontrolliert
wie hier an der deutsch tschechischen
grenze 9000 reisende wurden in den
letzten tagen wieder zurückgeschickt
heute kündigt das saarland an seine
einreisebestimmungen zu verschärfen an
der grenze zum französischen
verwaltungsbezirk modell ist künftig ein
negativer pcr test nötig von dänemark
bis spanien von belgien bis ungarn zehn
eu staaten führen gerade grenzkontrollen
durch deutschland erhielt diese woche
dafür einen beschwerdebrief aus brüssel
wir haben gesehen dass manche länder in
sachen mobilität und reisefreiheit
eigene wege gegangen sind und das für
sich selbst geregelt haben
die kommission ist zu recht
eingeschritten und hat daran erinnert
dass es so nicht geht
für den eu gipfel heute musste niemand
grenzen überqueren krisentreffen wieder
nur im videomodus auf dem tisch ein
vorstoß aus österreich ein digitaler
impfpass soll allen die geimpft oder
nachweislich immun sind mehr freiheiten
ermöglichen das ziel dessen ist dass wir
nicht im dauer lockdown verharren wollen
sondern dass wir endlich wieder
innerhalb europas frei reisen können
ganz gleich ob geschäftlich oder als
urlaub wir wollen dass menschen wieder
veranstaltungen gastronomie kultur sport
und vieles andere mehr genießen und
erleben können voraussetzung dafür dass
der impfstoff schneller als bisher
produziert und verkauft wird auch
darüber wollen die regierungschefs beim
gipfel
heute beraten bringen wir anne gellinek
mit dazu in brüssel genannt anne es
fällt auf das thema impfpass ist immer
wieder auf der tagesordnung der eu ist
denn absehbar ob da jetzt entscheidungen
fallen
nein eine entscheidung über einen
impfpass wird es auf diesem eu gipfel
noch nicht geben aber der druck der
länder deren wirtschaften vom tourismus
abhängig sind der steigt eins davon ist
österreich wie gerade gesehen kanzler
kurz schlägt eine app vor die darüber
auskunft geben soll ob jemand geimpft
ist oder nicht und er droht auch ganz
offen damit sieben notfalls im
alleingang einzuführen
noch weiter gehen griechenland und
zypern sie verhandeln bereits mit israel
darüber ob nicht geimpfte israelische
touristen ihren sommerurlaub dieses jahr
in griechenland und zypern verbringen
könnten die bremser in dieser debatte
sind die großen länder deutschland und
frankreich ihnen geht ihnen ist diese
diskussion viel zu früh sie sagen man
könne darüber reden erst wenn ein
großteil der europäischen bevölkerung
geimpft ist und davon kann man ja wohl
im moment noch nicht sprechen also die
herausforderung ist ein weiteres mal
einen gemeinsamen europäischen weg zu
finden den laden zusammenzuhalten und zu
vermeiden dass einzelne eu-länder in
diesem sommer eigene urlaubs und reise
regeln erlassen
an den green egg zdf brüssel herzlichen
dank für diese erläuterungen österreich
geht im kampf gegen korona bewusst
eigene wege auch um die einschränkungen
zu lockern
vor gut zwei wochen öffneten die
geschäfte wieder
jetzt erst recht lautet die devise
testen testen testen denn wer zum
friseur will oder in die schule braucht
die bescheinigung dass sie oder er nicht
infiziert ist
das sind inzwischen 210.000
untersuchungen jeden tag die sieben tage
incidence in österreich ist trotz allem
gestiegen von 100 auf 145 britta hilpert
jetzt mit einer bilanz der widersprüche
im zillertal ist europas größter hotspot
der südafrika mutante seit zwei wochen
sollen freiwillige massentests aufspüren
wer positiv ist
wer sie vielleicht trägt trotzdem
entwickelte sich in mayrhofen im
zillertal ein hotspot im hot spot der
ort wird ab samstag abgeriegelt nur mit
negativen test kommt man raus freiwillig
bekommen wir keinen verlässlichen
gesamtüberblick und dementsprechend soll
eine testpflicht vorgesehen werden
seit in österreich am 8 februar die
geschäfte wieder öffnen durften werden
anti gen tests im ganzen land kostenlos
angeboten für den friseurbesuch ist der
negativ testen und voraussetzung auch in
schulen gibt es regelmäßig tests
freiwillig machen auch die arabisch und
seine mitarbeiter alle drei tage einen
antigen selbsttests er kostet sechs euro
50 pro nase er gibt mehr sicherheit für
die ganze belegschaft denn einmal wurde
hier im selbsttest jemand positiv
getestet sie habe keinerlei symptome
dennoch positiv und wir haben dadurch
eine größere auswahl verhindern können
kostenlose tests über all das sollte die
infektionsgefahr durch lockerungen
ausgleichen doch experten zweifeln die
massentest haben sich nicht wirklich
bewertung das infektionsgeschehen nach
unten zu drücken
denn die infektionszahlen steigen in
österreich nicht nur weil man jetzt mehr
fälle findet weniger lockdown mehr tests
so hat die politik in österreich
entschieden
doch die strategie funktioniert nur
eingeschränkt nicht alle lassen sich
gern freiwillig testen die
nachverfolgung könnte besser sein
die genauigkeit der tests auch und so
schwindet die hoffnung auf die öffnung
der gastronomie mitte märz im gegenteil
es droht ein erneuter shutter baden
württemberg schlägt jetzt einen
ähnlichen weg vor dass wir mit hilfe von
schnelltests teile des einzelhandels der
gastronomie und museen wieder öffnen
das steht laut deutscher presseagentur
in einem papier aus stuttgart für die
nächsten beratungen von bund und ländern
und auch im bundestag ging es heute um
schnelltests und zwar schnell
daniel jonsson ungewohnt einheitlich
heute die kritik gleich drei
oppositionsparteien daran dass die
bundesregierung das schnell testen
wenn es darum geht dass bildung das
kunst das kultur das gastronomie das
sport damit verhindert wird dann trifft
es die gesamte bevölkerung dass weitere
aufschieben von kostenlosen schnelltest
durch die bundesregierung versteht
wirklich niemand mehr
9 milliarden euro zusagen für die
lufthansa das geht ruckzuck das ist gar
kein problem aber die einführung
kostenloser schnelltest erfolgt erst
nach monaten öffentlicher debatte wann
wird das passieren die wird das sein
wann wird das greifen das kann doch wohl
nicht wahr sein wir reden hier um
menschenleben minister sparen hatte
massenhafte tests ab nächstem montag in
aussicht gestellt das kanzleramt im plan
passiert man werde das thema beim
nächsten bund länder treffen in eine
gesamtstrategie einbetten wie lange es
dauert bis ein solches system
installiert ist kann ich auf den tag
genau noch nicht sagen sagte die
kanzlerin der faz es wird aber im märz
seien die afg sieht umfangreiche tests
skeptisch zu unsicher zu teuer
mehr noch vergleichbar ist die pflicht
zu bestellt ist also unserer sicht mit
einem indirekten impfzwang dies wird von
der afg das wissen sie entschieden
abgelehnt die spd schloss sich der
kritik am minister an und schlangen zum
kurs der regierung mitunter so
distanziert als wäre sie nicht selbst
teil von mir und ich sage ihnen ganz
klar der lock down ist nicht der weg aus
dieser krise der weg aus der krise ist
impfen testen und kontakte nachverfolgen
und wir erleben doch in diesen tagen
alle das ist kluge konzepte gibt der
wunsch zentrale aspekte der pandemie im
parlament zu behandeln wurde heute
erfüllt entscheidungen dabei wird es
erst bei der mpk geben nächsten mittwoch
einen wert auf den viele schauen in der
debatte um shutdown und lockerungen der
steigt gerade wieder an die sieben tage
incidents liegt bundesweit jetzt bei
61,7 das robert koch institut meldet
11.869 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
das sind 1662 mehr als vergangenen
donnerstag 385 menschen sind in
verbindung mit 19 gestorben
nicht nur diese zahlen zeigen die
zwickmühle in der wir alle stecken
dürfen wir überhaupt wieder öffnen
müssten wir das dringend tun von der
politik erwarten die menschen
perspektiven sie stellt jetzt
vorsichtige schritte in aussicht und
gleichzeitig warnen andere vor den
folgen
zwischen öffnen und bangen torge bode
und dominik löschmeister bettina weiler
hat heute eine vorsichtige perspektive
bekommen einkaufen nach elektronische
registrierung und voranmeldung der
kunden könnte ab märz in ihrer boutique
in wiesbaden möglich sein
begeistert ist sie trotzdem nicht ich
stelle mir die frage wieso kann man
nicht komplett öffnet so wie wir es
vorher auch schon hatten vor dem lock
down und dass wir halt eben dann zwei
kunden ins geschäft lassen wir haben
alle ein super hygiene konzept hessen
hält behutsame lockerungen für möglich
bei guten inzidenz zahlen heute hat der
ministerpräsident einen perspektiv plan
vorgestellt vorsichtig raus aus dem
scheinbar nicht enden wollen den
shutdown
das ist eine orientierung wenn es gut
läuft kann das so sein wenn es schlecht
läuft muss man es vielleicht wieder
zurücknehmen und in einer zeit der
unsicherheit muss man besonnen bleiben
deshalb werden dass kleinere schritte
seien aber durchaus wichtige lockern
oder nicht und wie heftig würde uns eine
dritte welle treffen
seit beginn der pandemie haben
intensivmediziner daten erhoben und
ausgewertet
entwickelt haben sie daraus ein
prognosemodell dass die auswirkungen
einer möglichen dritten welle berechnen
soll werden dazu verschiedene faktoren
hinzu genommen die häufig ist die
mutation in deutschland vorhanden wie
viele sind wir in folge gehen davon aus
dass die geimpften keinen schweren
intensiver laufende haben während der
lebensbedrohlich ist und alle diese
faktoren haben jetzt ausgewertet und in
die zukunft geschaut
das ergebnis impfen wir in dem gleichen
tempo weiter und wird der shutdown ab
dem siebten märz gelockert könnte die
zahl der belegten intensivbetten im
schlimmsten fall auf über 25.000 steigen
wird bei gleichbleibendem tempo erst ab
april vorsichtig geöffnet würde die
intensivbetten belegung nur um die 5000
liegen so das rechenmodell das ist eine
große belastung aber das ist eine
machbare herausforderung und wenn wir
dann eben dazu impfen dann sind wir am
ende des dritten quartals glaube ich
dass wir die pandemie bewältigt haben
wir einen zusammen
die mediziner haben heute nur
verschiedene mögliche szenarien
vorgestellt ob sie ein treffen oder
nicht hängt vom verhalten jedes
einzelnen und politischen entscheidungen
ab mehr zu diesem prognosemodell in
unserer zdf heute app jetzt geht es um
schwere vorwürfe gerade in diesen zeiten
ein deal mit corona schutzmasken die
staatsanwaltschaft münchen ermittelt
gegen den csu fraktionsvize im bundestag
georg nüßlein wegen des anfangsverdachts
der bestechlichkeit
nach unbestätigten medienberichten soll
er schutzmasken unter anderem an die
bundesregierung vermittelt und dafür
eine provision kassiert haben
außerdem soll er das geld nicht
versteuert haben zuvor hatte der
bundestag die immunität von nüßlein
aufgehoben klaus brodbeck der mann mit
der maske und das geschäft mit den
masken sollte sich der vorwurf
bestätigen
der politische schaden wäre wohl enorm
man muss sich das vorstellen ein
führender gesundheitspolitiker der cdu
csu bereichert sich bei der masken
beschaffung seiner eigenen regierung
also wenn sich diese vorwürfe erhärten
dann muss das natürlich massive
konsequenzen haben
600.000 euro soll nüßlein für die
vermittlung eines markenherstellers an
die gesundheitsministerien in bayern und
im bund erhalten haben die csu im
bundestag weist auf die
unschuldsvermutung zugunsten
verdächtiger hin
alle anderen fraktionen heute auch diese
aber fordern ein lobbyregister das was
wir bisher wissen ist definitiv kein
kavaliersdelikt und von daher muss jetzt
umfassend aufgeklärt werden und wir
verlangen auch gleichzeitig dass wir
endlich voran kann bei den themen mehr
transparenz politisch wird es aber
natürlich ein schlechtes licht auf das
parlament und deshalb sollten wir jetzt
unsere transparenz anstrengungen
verstärken etwa mit einem hobby
transparenzgesetz die cdu csu muss ihre
blockade auflösen für mehr transparenz
wir brauchen mehr transparenz
nachvollziehbarkeit und offenlegung
bislang bremste die union solche
bestrebungen dabei wurde mit müssen nun
schon das dritte fraktionsmitglied
auffällig politik darf nicht käuflich
sein und sie darf auch nicht den
anschein machen dass sie käuflich ist 13
objekte wurden heute durchsucht mit
deutschland und den liechtenstein
darunter auch wohnungen und büros von
nüßlein
klingt nach viel arbeit für die
ermittler etwas mehr als zwei jahre ist
es jetzt her dass rechtsextreme chats
innerhalb der hessischen polizei für
schlagzeilen sorgten
jetzt hat die staatsanwaltschaft
frankfurt am main anklage gegen vier
aktive und ehemalige beamte erhoben
ein polizeioberkommissar wird
beschuldigt ende 2018 in mehreren
whatsapp gruppen ns propaganda und
rassistische beiträge an kollegen
verschickt zu haben
außerdem wird ihm unerlaubter
waffenbesitz vorgeworfen
bei den anderen geht es um den verrat
von dienstgeheimnissen und den besitz
von bildern die den missbrauch von
kindern zeigen
zuerst sprach das land berlin das verbot
aus dann folgte sofort die razzia am
heute morgen gegen eine islamistische
vereinigung die propagiert nach
einschätzung der behörden
terroranschläge und ist äußerst radikal
850 beamte durchsuchten in berlin und
brandenburg räume und beschlagnahmten
beweismittel die gefahr des
islamistischen terrorismus sei weiterhin
hoch sagt berlins innensenator romanesco
war jetzt mit den einzelheiten noch in
der dunkelheit begannen die
durchsuchungen im zentrum stehen
mitglieder eines radikal salafistischen
vereins 26 objekte waren betroffen 24
allein in berlin
der innensenator hatte die vereinigung
verboten
die yamato berlin alias david berlin
glorifiziert den sogenannten islamischen
staates und seine führer die vereinigung
befürwortet den bewaffneten dschihad
selbst bis zur durchführung von
selbstmordanschlägen mitglieder sollen
die berliner fossil at moschee besucht
haben sie galt als anlaufadresse des
breitscheidplatz attentäters amri vor
vier jahren wurde der trägerverein
verboten bezüge soll es auch zur gruppe
um avatar gegeben haben der gestern zu
einer langen haftstrafe verurteilt wurde
den bestialischen mord an samuel partie
soll die gruppe befürwortet haben der
lehrer wurde vergangenes jahr in
frankreich enthauptet bei den
mitgliedern handelt es sich um radikale
antisemiten hieß es heute
ihre rhetorik aggressiv militante die
gruppe geht etwa davon aus dass die
große schlacht das ist ein zitat das die
große schlacht noch kommen werde
das und auch dass es ein zitat
polizisten die köpfe abgeschnitten
werden und in einem gebot in einem gebet
heißt es an einer stelle
lasst ihre flugzeuge abstürzen zwei
mitglieder der rund 20 personen starken
salafisten gruppe sind als islamistische
gefährder eingestuft konkrete
anschlagspläne seien bislang nicht
bekannt und jetzt in der sendung eine
statistik unter dem eindruck der
pandemie die zumindest einen positiven
trend zeigt noch nie verzeichnete das
statistische bundesamt so wenige
tödliche unfälle wie 2020 im verkehr
starben 2007 124 menschen ein minus von
gut zehn prozent zum vorjahr der grund
es war weniger los auf den straßen gegen
den trend allerdings stieg die zahl der
getöteten e bike fahrer auf 137 das sind
19 prozent mehr so das waren die
nachrichten auf der erde
jetzt gibt es neues vom mars dieses
panorama bild erreicht uns nach 472
millionen zurückgelegten kilometern
allein das muss man sich erst mal
vorstellen
und es zeigt einen ausgetrockneten see
aufgenommen hat es der nasa rovers evans
der auf dem mars nach mikroskopisch
kleinen spuren früheren lebens fanden
soll und mit diesem bild in unglaublich
klare auflösung können wir alle fast
schon von zu hause mit suchen
ich glaube ich habe da was gesicht du
dich ja mach lieber den sport ja gute
nachrichten gibt es da zumindest vom
mars nicht für borussia mönchengladbach
denn die das team wartet weiter auf
positive nachrichten
im achtelfinal hinspiel gegen manchester
city das khroma bedingt im budapest
stattfand verlor das team von marco rose
mit 0 2 und steckt daher mitten drin
mini krise erneut kein erfolgserlebnis
zuletzt drei pflichtspiel niederlagen
ein unentschieden schwierig die
situation für gladbach und trainer marco
rose der gegner gestern aber eine nummer
zu groß natürlich eine sehr verdiente
niederlage gegen wegen absolutes topteam
aber ich kann den jungs keinen vorwurf
machen manchester city deutlich
überlegen erzielte zwei nahezu
identische tore bernardo silva mit dem 1
0 in der ersten hälfte und in der 64
minute war es dann gabriel jesus nach
vorlage von bernardo silva kurz zuvor
hat der player die erste chance für die
borussen gehabt eine artistische einlage
fast der ausgleich aber insgesamt waren
die gladbacher viel zu harmlos die
ethikkommission des fußball
weltverbandes fifa hat entschieden das
verfahren gegen franz beckenbauer den
ehemaligen dfb präsidenten theo
zwanziger und den früheren dfb
generalsekretär horst schmidt nicht
weiter zu verfolgen die
korruptionsvorwürfe gegen die drei rund
um die vergabe der wm 2006 seien
verjährt heißt es und jetzt noch zur
nordischen ski wm in oberstdorf und der
entscheidung im skispringen der frauen
die allerdings ohne medaillen für
deutschland ausging katharina althaus
wurde beste deutsche auf rang zehn
die siegerin kommt aus slowenien und die
ist nach dem springen vollkommen von der
rolle emma klinik für slowenien gold bei
der entscheidung von der normalschanze
100,5 meter es ist die erste wm medaille
für sloweniens skispringerinnen
überhaupt beste deutsche bei diesem
einzelspringen die oberstdorferin
katharina althaus auf platz zehn
folglich noch mehr zu springers haben
slowenien voll und wie norwegen und der
japanerin takanashi die slowenen und
vollkommen aus dem häuschen für die
deutschen nordischen kann es nur besser
werden in den nächsten wm-tagen
vielleicht schon morgen im
teamwettbewerb oder bei den kombinierern
diesem morgen auch dran
vielen dank hat ja man sich an den
letzten besuch beim friseur kaum noch
erinnern kann und es langsam überfällig
wird dann passiert sowas wir können
mitfühlen mit diesem schaaf in
australien zwar ausgebüxt und kam
jahrelang ungeschoren davon
doch so ein hippie leben ist anstrengend
35 kilo wog am ende die wolle und nach
dem termin beim schaf scherer kaum
wiederzuerkennen nur ein mäntelchen muss
jetzt sein weil es doch etwas zu lange
haare haben auch vorteile zumindest
zumal es in deutschland jetzt wieder
kühler wird katja honnefer hat gleich
alle details ich empfehle ihnen das
heute journal mit der kollegin marietta
slomka um 21 uhr 45 und von uns im team
19 war es das für heute gerne morgen
wieder aber erst wünschen wir hinein
einen sehr angenehmen abend
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren es
war jetzt ja ungewöhnlich warm für ende
februar das ändert sich jetzt das liegt
an einer kleinen kaltfront sie sehen
hier dieses wolkenband das dach von
nordwesten heranzieht hinter dem
wolkenband lockern die wolken allerdings
schon wieder auf da verbirgt sich der
sonnenschein fürs wochenende
heute nacht fällt erstmal regen ungefähr
zwischen dem spreewald und dem
niederrhein in süddeutschland ist es
dagegen klar und darauf sinken die
temperaturen auf werte zwischen plus ein
und minus zwei grad unter den dichteren
wolken bleibt es bei 8 bis 4 grad bilder
und im norden ist die kalte luft schon
angekommen da sinken die werte auf 4 bis
2 grad und dort bleibt es an den küsten
von ost und nordsee auch morgen am
kühlsten mit so etwa acht bis zehn grad
sonst gibt es in norddeutschland maximal
12 grad und häufig scheint die sonne bei
west nordwest wird der regen zieht
weiter südwärts erreicht schon
vormittags sachsen und den harz und am
nachmittag dann auch süddeutschland bis
zum abend regnet es dann auch im
nordschwarzwald und in der oberpfalz
aber südlich der donau bleibt es wohl
bis zum abend trocken und zum teil auch
richtig sonnig und deswegen steigen dort
die temperaturen noch mal auf 14 bis 18
grad in den nächsten tagen geht es
freundlich aber doch deutlich kühler
weiter schönen abend noch